du pur pour se strient du premier jeudi
du mois où on va une nouvelle fois joué
un tournoi
enfin vous allez jouer un tournant fait
quoi a commenté avec avec avec fanien
fabien qui va bientôt arriver donc le
toit qui démarre à 20h30
donc dans 30 minutes il ya déjà pas mal
de ce qui ce soir déjà onze inscrits
donc un tournoi qui risque d'être assez
relevé ce soir je n'arrive pas à revoir
la liste des inscrits j'ai un bug pour
le moment je n'arrive pas à ok je la
liste des inscrits c'est bon en fait y'a
pas mal d'habitués
il ya pas mal d'habitués ils sont déjà
là ils sont au courant du tournoi on
espère que y avoir des petits nouveaux
qui vont venir se mêler à la bagarre que
j'aimerais bien savoir si le live marche
ou pas normalement et live mais bon
j'aimerais bien avoir confirmation de
personnes dans le chat si possible ce
serait pas mal si possible ce serait
sympa et moi même on me dit le fus
déconnecté non non non c'est parti c'est
parti c'est bon tu tournes d'emera
démarre viande en 29 minutes a laissé un
petit peu les gens j'en arrivais les
douze maintenant 3 c'est vraiment
peut-être patenôtre georges tron avait
réussi à faire une fois 27 participants
n'est pas mal parti on est pas mal parti
22 29 ans qu'on a ça marche je salue
donc gros chat qui est là d'ailleurs
n'oubliez pas donc je vais mettre une
première fois le lien sur le tchat
mais je le remettrai je remettrai plus
tard le lien du post facebook pour
trouver le tournoi bat soyez sympas les
mecs un essai de partager sur facebook
vous venez tout tous les premiers jeudis
du mois participer au tournoi donc si
vous vouliez partager sur facebook pour
qu'il ya un maximum de gens puissent
être au courant de ce tournoi ce serait
très très sympa de votre part donc ça
serait sympa parce que ça t'a côté on
vous fait on fait ces tournois là
mensuellement et du coup bah c'est sympa
si vous aidez aussi un peu de votre côté
donc une nouvelle fois en partageant en
partageant sur sur facebook on ne
demande pas tout le temps j'avais fait
un peu le même coup pour les situations
possibles ce que c'est un gros événement
mais là pour pour ces tournois là
évidemment plus l'adjointe participe lui
c'est marrant donc c'est sympa si si
vous donnez un coup de main si vous
donnez un coup de main avec avec avec
vos réseaux sociaux
en ce jour de roland garros roland
garros qui a débuté dimanche
je crois qu'il ya richard gasquet qui
est pas mal parti dans son match ce soir
et quand je les quitte et dominé le
premier set de la tête et des épaules
il a gagné le premier set il a gagné le
premier set richard gagné le premier set
6 jeux à 1
donc un valeureux voir dominicain donc
aller en attendant fab et en attendant
un peu tout tout ce beau monde moi je
vais je vais taper peut-être deux trois
bulles est alors il ya un truc que
j'aimerais bien faire aussi s'est créé
en fait tout simplement créé l'ouverture
leeroy jenkins donc c'est quelque chose
que je planifie de faire l'un mois de
juin on a cet objectif là donc créé la
taxe leeroy je pense que l'attak leeroy
doit commencer plus ou moins normalement
genre on doit faire un truc normal genre
peut-être dès quatre espèces de
préparation cavaliers des deux cavaliers
ou deux peut-être dans l'esprit je sais
pas cavalier f3 faut qu'on réfléchisse
ensemble et après près d'un courrier
lire oeil jenkins cap j'arriverais je
sais pas quel pionsat peut être mais il
faut qu'ils ce que le pion soit perdu
assez rapidement fait ce père qu'il faut
il qu'ils fassent de trois cases et
qu'il a il se suicidait un peu dans le
camp adverse mais faut pas que faut pas
que ce soit le pion à chaud le pion à ou
des trucs qu'on a l'habitude de faire
peut-être que je serai le pion de ça
pour être le pion b donc ce soir c'est
pas les parties avec avec les
spectateurs
[Musique]
achat bh donc fait venir un autre jeudi
où on joue des parties plus libre là ce
soir c'est le tournoi dont elle fait des
idées pour cette nature l'eren jenkins
n'hésitez pas à donner moi des idées on
va jouer correctement mais il faut il
faut trouver ce que ce que ça pourrait
être le gambit jenkins on pourrait
l'appeler
j'espère que vous connaissez la vidéo si
vous connaissez pas la vie de l'héroïne
jenkins il va falloir y sur youtube et
chercher un tapez l'iron jenkins et vous
devriez trouver cette vidéo qui était je
crois sur world of warcraft vidéo très
très marrante donc que je vous
recommande de chercher donc pour le
moment vous va aller brutalisé un peu
tout ça avec le pion f allez hop on va
tous poussés et puis on arrive qu'ils
sont là ils avancent c'est un peu
peut-être idiot ce que j'ai fait mais ok
a du coup invoqué angers 4 pourquoi pas
du coup on va donner ce pion là on va
récupérer suis là attention peut-être
d'amincissement il ne joue pas du couffo
f5 où la ceni bullet il faut pas il faut
pas l'oublier aller le fou en d6
dame vers h4 ça mange pas de pain il
peut y avoir du s3 m'en donnez moi où
j'ai pas juste pas vu ça avec le fourgon
g4 le pion f3 probablement pour essayer
d'aller porter surnombre à les pions
pranger de il n'a pas le temps de
prendre angers 4 passes qui a pris il
n'a pas le temps de prendre g4 comme ça
parce qu'il a prises en f2 s'apprend
f-22 partout c'est wang toulouse j'ai
envie de tenir tu as envie de perdre
du coup vous prend à pokémon est là
davantage sein qui on va revenir et du
tour et six tours j'ai six pour le
moment c'est contré alors effet retour
g4 il se défend assez bien flou
reconnaître et moi je vous assez mal ok
du coup oui on va accepter les changes
des dames enfin accepté va faire les
changements et les changes les dames
plutôt qu'un échec ne sert à rien
n'était pas loin commence à mal jouer à
un moment donné dans cette partie le roi
qui va réussir à s'évader mais pas très
loin en fait
et du coup le cavaly qui est très bien
placé au quai le roi qui monte
ok continue à monter le roi qui est
toujours là aie aie aie aie aie aie
du coup c'est perdu
ok on va abandonner alors à récupérer
fabien à main j'ai perdu pas mal de
points le cinquième un bon classement
yo yo femme attend tu mets ta caméra web
sport je suis en train de dire oh mais
que j'ai envie d'inventer l'ouverture
l'iran jenkins mais je sais pas si tu
connais la vidéo tu connais pas à temps
à touget sur le site le haut puisque je
fais oui tu peux aller sur le site tu
venais pas la vidéo les rues jenkins sur
world of warcraft la main ça bah en fait
c'est un truc mythique tu connais le jeu
world of warcraft pas trop peu vite fait
naître une folle et conclure des
territoires à tous ouais c'était pas mal
et tu faisais des cats
ouais bon en gros je te montrerai quand
tu viens demain mais elle est énorme la
vidéo en gros tu as des mecs ils
discutent de faire une carte google
enfin tu as une quête vraiment dur donc
les mecs qui sont là ils sont au taquet
y réfléchisse comment faire et tout ça
j'en ris discute toi tu dois faire ça
toi tu vas faire ça alors discussion
dure à peu près dix minutes et en fait
c'est un mec qui en a marre et eagle
jenkins et il envoie son personnage et à
cause de lui tout le monde se fait buter
en fait jean ça le soulever disent que
tout est faux que tu utilises un sort
machin et genre à la fin il est ok mais
juste j'en avais marre et et je suis
montré la vidéo excellente le mec gueule
et du coup je disais mais qui ferait
qu'on trouve une ouverture le gambit
jenkins aux échecs
genre tu balances un pur deux équipes
heures complètement débile quoi ton 20
pions comme un débile à un moment donné
et ugl ligue 1 tu de crédit tout leur
quota
tu veux tu t'en fous en fait tenté dans
l'esprit à fond du coup il faut ils sont
pas très nombreux dans le chat quand ils
soient ces endroits dans le tournoi
femme hockey letton breton pas nombreux
voici son 13 déjà ils étaient douze
cantons a démarré là ils sont treize je
leur ai dit de partager du tournant au
maximum sur facebook mais qui n'ont pas
si le fond
j'aurais envoyé le lien je leur envoie
le lien partagé à fond c'est vrai ils
sont ils se gardent le ton a pour eux
ils veulent pas que les autres jouent
mais je le bats le partage et non
attendre une coup je refais un de
boulettes en attendant on pourra parler
de la master class et à la cia
nathan comment on va faire je vais
arriver
une datation d'écran je pense que tu
suis tournoi non tu essaies de suivre
c'est sûr qu'avec le partage on fasse
tout péter enfin on peut essayer
remarque pas on essaye à ses quelque
part plus simple pour ceux là mêmes
parties machin ouais non mais là ils
sont pas sur le chat ils sont ils sont
ils sont mous du ils sont venus
j'ai envie de dire oui du caleçon en
fait comment les gars c'est trop de
mouvements bâtiment va le lien twitch je
le partagerai
en fait pas évident parce que du coup je
n'étais pas sur ce carré pareil je vais
te l'envoyer que je vais te l'envoyer à
tu venir d'augmenter cheveux tu envoies
par facebook en même temps même plus le
parcours où le discount appelbaum hop
vous me vient tweed ou alors le chat
bugs
nancy 10 20h30 ça commence quand les
matchs sinon 20h30 le tournoi 30
tous les premiers jeudis du mois
automatiquement tu tombes sur le tournoi
est peut-être une surprise c'est ce que
j'écrivais tout à l'heure sur internet
dont une surprise bah j'ai écrit vos
mails que s'il ya des mecs qui jouent ce
particulièrement bien ils peuvent
peut-être être sélectionné en équipe de
france c'est pas nous c'est pas parce
que tu es là peut-être tu charges et
loire on sais pas peut-être non j'ai bon
le premier abord m'ont d'ailleurs c'est
quelle gamme ébloui par sa classe
tu sais pas mais aussi aura peut-être
des places entre autres chez sig a gagné
voilà on ne sait pas d'ailleurs on a une
nouvelle recrue pour la prochaine ligue
arabe cette date à confirmer
j'ai recruté j'ai recruté et la nouvelle
recrue me parler éventuellement de
streamer stone
il était assez d'accord avec moi la
nouvelle recrue peut-être qu'il faut
arrêter d stream sur les échecs kevin on
a une recrue qui a c'est à kiel qui a
été championne de france d'ailleurs
l'art plus enfin il a été champion de
france mais comme c'est drôle quand on
veut parler au féminin nil où l on se
bat on sait pas on sait pas si ça peut
être une vie ça peut être un garçon mais
c'est un peu tiens heures j'ai mon match
ce soir avec sainté joue contre khider
ce soir sur mon jeu mais c'est un match
par jour on peut être non mais c'est
vrai je pars je joue tous les soirs
tu peux pas un truc à l'élite non je
n'attends pas une semaine mais si j'ai
un mec qui s'entraîne en revanche non il
peut pas louer la forcément ya un match
par jour donc le mec tu vas faire
l'entraînement la journée le match le
soir je suis contre qui je maintiens
non je suis 3e du championnat paris
saint-germain 12 points bordeaux 10
points sans teddy smith 10 on n'est pas
mal alors on joue qui ce soir où est le
calendrier je fais des tactiques mais je
ne sais pas contre qui joue contre eux
qui jouent calendrier alors ce soir
alors après non mais à 16 ans on joue
contre marseille à l'extérieur au match
quand même deux mecs qui défendent
change pas tactique 1 passe à dix monnet
paquet en attaque on attends tu penses
que je n'attends donc un gros match pour
nous ce soir face aux relations directes
ou stuff tf1 tu peux le suivre il faut
le suivre à la fin presque en direct et
en conditions du direct
c'est hyper stressant fait du coup je
regarde plus en direct un vrai que les
scores avoisinant les conditions du
direct que tu ne fumes non feinte stream
2 a comme ice à 22h alors attend les
avants de toulouse qui veut jouer alors
temps il n'a pas l'air d'être achevée h3
je suis un peu obligé parce que bon
voilà c'est à dire que là de plus en
plus de gens sur chasse points comme ne
font plus d'heureux match après cette
ouverture d'ailleurs il ya plein de mecs
en fait ils refusent de rejouer après
son sa réfutation des échecs bruit
derrière et c'est fantastique que vous
faire dire que lâcheté change des dames
et en fait je te marche
c'est horrible
il peut faire télé prendre cinq néo
c'est regrettable
grand bien fou prend en fait c'est
célébrer et chacun sait c'est hier mais
qui nous a fait un type d'ailleurs il
m'a fait marrer ils continuer cette
chaîne sur les vrais échecs ou non pour
ce spécialiste international du match 2
1 de ce que j'aime c'est la rai là il a
hésité et je veux dire un truc je pense
et c'est le niveau de jeu là qui te le
trouble d'ailleurs le pion à vii je vais
aller en déceptions achète et je vais
faire une dame
je vais prendre ma grosbill est base y
prend le car il y va du bien à l'attaqué
mais si bien mais l'immense île veut pas
manger
allez montez le pion non je déconne
c'est une blague m'abandonne bah ouais
mais bon voilà bah les brises échec dès
qu'il a fait cavalier assiste à lui h3g
cannes direct boom perd pas de temps et
on va faire pareil
voilà tu vas y dis ils le sont regarde
voyage non mais mariage 6,1 l'an
prochain à une défense ont des fonctions
au quai 20 minutes tu regardes ça t'as
l'air d'halluciner femmes peuvent
rentrer
tiens je viens de me cultiver pas sa sé
ta nou ridicule c'est tellement ridicule
tu viens apprendre en fait pour pour le
top 12 d'année prochaine pour tous à
regarder bah c'est pas mal le flot à 3
tiens c'est marrant alors que ses succès
sacrifice adam
bah c'est pas mal joué d'ailleurs bref
le temps je regarde le classement elo du
genre moi non de notre cour huit points
comme le faux classement tu regardais en
fait voilà le classement des mecs le
field en fait pas au classement internet
sert à rien fait je regarde le fond
grosse teuf country in france
alors oui baisse je suis la voile a
perdu deux points le ring du centre bell
en tout et pour tout
mais après c'est un voilà c'est un
classement anecdotique
jag et un vert même si ça coûte roger
perd 3,2 au top 12 automatiquement tu
perd 1,6
ça fait deux excuse moi j'ai dû mater je
suis très très très déçu donc donc
d'accord voilà 18e j'ai repensé à
l'égard si on joue pas la première
est-ce qu'on équipe du toit au pas à
deux c'est fini
c'est des vrais tournant après on est
que disent être là allez faut partager
un peu sur facebook les gens allez on
partage sur facebook et cornetto tout au
comptant est bien de dépasser les 2006
ah ouais cool mais tu sais qu'il est
content il était géré il a dit noah il
était très content là bas machin un
achat par questions philosophiques
est-ce que 25 98 tout 26 02 ça change
vraiment beaucoup barre psychologique
mans sinon se joint donc au final je me
rappelle que mur face étaient très
contents par action et l'eau mais quand
il est rentré dans le top 100 mondial
alors salut c'est vrai c'est pas
intuitif je trouve pas non plus le link
du tournoi bah il faut il faut il faut
s'inscrire
je fais un lien toutes les semaines les
mecs toutes les semaines ya un lien qui
explique tout vous pouvez le trouver sur
le lien de juin m sur le sur les choses
facebook où tout est expliqué ce comment
s'inscrire au club élite stream puis
comment trouver du tournant pour moi
donc c'est en haut à droite sur chaque
point comme vous avez l'échiquier ici
puis c'est juste à droite faut aller
dans les tournois et est bon c'est quand
même
c'est pas mégafuite yves meyer impulsif
mais bon ça m'a quand même vers
trouvable et sur le lien tout est
expliqué il n'y a pas moyen de pas
trouvé bien dire que je vous recommande
de partager et personne ne l'a partagée
et fable la loose
du coup du coup il ya personne n'y a
personne qui partage le truc les mecs
qui relierait le tournoi focus a manqué
de le jouer partager tout ça non non non
on pense que je peux quand même de
partage d'après toi nous avons ouais euh
bravo à vous bien trouvé bien trouvé
bien vu dupoux ouais bon les gars n'a
besoin de vous qu'on sait comme ça quand
on vous demande pas je sais pas vraiment
à une communauté on fait des trucs
ensemble ça tu part des choses qu'on
fasse toujours gratuits et tout mais
faut vous bougez pas parce qu'à deux on
peut jamais arriver et si on vend
correctement mais douze inscrits bon bah
c'est pas là en tentant de le faire on
est né chez pas c'est pas je vois pas ce
qui a troublé affaire de clients ça
c'est un truc qui échoue encore
satisfait pas le regarder une vidéo
qu'on fait sur sur youtube qui vous
plaît vous partagez pas c'est à dire ces
deux clics on par une femme
si vous aimez pas avant balaj moins de
personnes que vous aimez pas mais
j'imagine vu le nombre de pouces bleus
la plupart du temps et tout mais je sais
pas quoi ça va prend 4 secondes au temps
deux fois par semaine et nous ça peut
faire une grosse différence que chez
papa je comprends pas non traitement ça
nous aide bien
la queue que ce soit par mail mais avec
les gens à votre club sur facebook sur
twitter enfin c'est pas très compliqué
il va le voilà c'est juste ok il faut
pas non plus à harceler les gens je
comprends bien mais vous le feriez une
fois par mois même déjà ce serait ça
ferait un gros truc quoi ouais surtout
combien ça on ne demande pas à chaque
fois l'année pour le tournoi parce que
c'est un peu sympa qui est plus de gens
qui participent et tout ça on me demande
vraiment pas sur toutes les vidéos
si vous regardez on a fait combien juste
des vidéos en replay en neige à 470 sûr
sur youtube et je pense on a dû lui
demander d'en j'ai pas fait 25 vidéos
sur 470 ça me paraît pas énorme non mais
oh
allez moi je te fais un mulet temps
mais l'ivresse de stratégie rapidement
chez synck funambule est ça m'a vraiment
permis de passer un palier sans rire en
fait ça va je te jure en fait c'est toi
ça te fait rire mais non en fait c'est
pas drôle c'est juste que c'est hyper
déstabilisant quand tu joues en face en
fait rien moi quoi qu'il se passe de
toute façon j'en vois les pions et après
c'est parti
après ouais bon là c'est pas top top tu
vois mais bon je me bats le truc c'est
que lui peut pas du tout anticipé mais
qu en fait pas c'est plus difficile pour
lui d' anticiper on va dire là par
contre ça se passe pas bien mais bon
c'est parce que j'ai parlé avant c'est
pour ça
ok statut en échec au pied il compte en
ce qu'il a fait un échec c'est pas grave
on va prendre ça on va les clous et et
tu vois là même quand il n'ya plus les
deux mêmes sans reda on va l'essayer de
mince j'avais je pensais faire cailler
des cinq épreuves quatre cavaliers de
maths j'ai pas le temps même temps après
mais ya échec
on va le tenter
il n'est pas passé par messi tenir au
cas où rien de grave mais c'est pire
qu'un pion en fait c'est la sa qui tombe
il ya tout dit on je pense à tous ces
mythes maintenant ça marche pas y'a rien
qui marche en fait c'est vrai même si je
me fais maths noir concerne à 2 je vais
mater tour à sept et machin aïe aïe aïe
mais ils sont pas contents les personnes
qui à facebook n'est pas facebook non
pas vraiment ce sera très bas si vous
n'êtes pas facebook
bon voilà c'est à moi de partager sur
facebook mais baba ses dévotions
n'importe quel réseau social de toute
façon c'est le marché on met dix minutes
ce n'est pas facebook veut pas voir plus
tard mais au cas où après a juste d'en
parler toute façon qui faisait dans un
club aux gens du club dire voilà je dis
à tournoi machin casillas à n'importe
quoi fin fait un peu de pub sur les
activités qui est autour ça peut être en
va de même du partage ou orales au final
en fait après évidemment le plus simple
pour qu'on nous dit visible je trouve
c'est le partage sur les réseaux sociaux
mais bien sûr ce n'est pas le truc c'est
pas vous montrer
après ils sont un peu de bruit dit qu'un
le partage orale cédric ouais mais par
deux jours al pourquoi pas passer pas
mal toute façon se met donc en fait
j'attends quand même communauté vous la
plupart des gens n'ont pas n'ont pas
facebook qui je compte et iphone et mon
rien du coup du coup du coq et on a fait
un truc centriste book on va te faire
par email il parvint à la coupe renault
de téléphone vous appeler bon je n'ai
pas de téléphone non plus je n'ai pas
écrit par la fenêtre
sinon ce soit oui jouer au tournoi
bon là là vous aurez partager langue
points ne t'en veux plus plein non on
est pas mal
moi je suis permanente y faire ma
position bottes casque sans plus se sont
appréciés des bullet préfère le maté
quand même tu vois le hongrois en pluie
s'il peut être j'en fais une dernière
donc vous n'êtes pas au long du salon et
c'est encore plus vicieux nous sommes
maillot orange et toutes ces pubs bars
là tout ce qui est étranger un de base
ce n'est pas bleu blanc rouge suis assez
ça peut être aussi ça peut être est
aussi en fait ouvert très tôt par thème
par thème femmes et va très bien nous
sommes restés bien adapté à tous alors
évidemment un coût mais oui montady
djamena hosting
oui c'est vrai jamais un orage s'abat
scandinave faut le savoir quand est-ce
que ça se remonte ça ou pas du coup là
c'est peut-être un peu l'ouverture le
rock jenkins pour l'ado les hommes et à
des jeux me paraît que le roi c1 paraît
trop dans quoi je parle outre vrai j'ai
enlevé six mois je veux pas donner mon
pions non non vous donne vos données
dahouët voilà j'aurai carrier si tu veux
prendre le meilleur
il n'a pas le prendre ils flippent est
il suffit pas this is où il fait dans le
caleçon
ouais c'est petit c'est petit joueur
tout ça ça a peur de la démat de partout
il ya ma bouteille avant intrus gauche
ouais c'est pas les vrais échecs qu'ils
trouvent pas le tournoi il n'en peut
plus si la page facebook puisque sur le
lien facebook en fait j'ai tout expliqué
en plus c'est vrai bon cet ex tuant deux
membres à la fois sur le web et jiménez
que tu es sur le club du stream
mais maintenant le tournoi il faut
apparemment il est dans le club mais il
fallait dont la zone tu vas dans la zone
emea bras droit tu vas t'en tournoi et
c'est est-ce que vous ne jouez pas assez
sur ce point comme aussi fait qu'ils
sont trop sur des sites concurrents
voilà voilà lille ou fable il a partagé
bah bravo tu peux peut-être gagné
l'abonnement diamant n'est que tu nous
donnera peut-être ton
ton content parce qu'il ya un abonnement
gars diamant à gagner en plus je paye un
abonnement diamant à gagner demain comme
comme d'abord fait un nom et puis bon on
vous dit heureux sinon là vous avez pris
du retard mais ce bond n'est pas
facebook on sait mais twitter aussi vous
pouvez créer ça prend peu de temps et si
vous avez juste part de votre identité
vous mettez des ventes et à une pseudo
c'est bon mais donc si vous suivez de
chasse comme sur facebook sur twitter et
qu'on arrive en 3 min abonnés là il y
aura des abonnements à gagner offerts
des modes et des amants annuel en plus
monstrueux coup pour coup gratuit pour
moi non mais non c'est pas ça lui le
bruit chess à u2 igman grâce à ça c'est
des gens qui te suivent déjà qui tu es
déjà en anglais avant ils viennent quand
même en france et même même la barrière
de la langue si tu ne les gêne pas je
vois pas le temps à bitstream incroyable
bail et pourtant il y est tu es petit tu
es foutu regarder tournant à venir
peut-être que tu regardes les tournois
en cours et du coup sûr regarder tourner
en cours et pas les tournois à venir du
pouce est mort
[Applaudissements]
hsbc dévoila bonjour hhbc des faits a
été le vainqueur le mois dernier un qui
a son abonnement diamants il en est très
content j'ai parlé il m'a dit oui ma vie
j'en suis très content il m'a dit je me
sens diamant on va le faire mais on
pourra faire une interview de lâchage
bcd vrai pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
comment tu te sens tu es acheta que je
suis diamant peut-être parce que ce que
ce qu'il sent grandi kouassi les
meilleurs vision du jeu tout ça qu'est
ce que ça change
là il a gagné un tournoi le week-end
dernier il a fait quatre émissaires 5
automatiquement est ce que c'est bon il
ya forcément un rapport entre le tu vois
mais voilà la tête que vous pouvez tous
devenir des mondes diamant quoi bon
apprendre ou c'est pas gratuit
mais bon tu serais tu voulais d'abord
noir peu de pommade là le tournoi a
commencé fab
c'est parti ok alors on suit qui il ya
comme une joueur plein de joueurs ok pas
mal déjà pas de pad exemple bon désolé
pour les retardataires mais ça les
regarde qui skins est ce que tu veux
diskin notre ami suisse cois qui joue
entre mehdi contre mehdi zollitsch 83
qu'un joueur qui m'a écrit il m'a dit
kevin je ne peux pas jouer c'est le
ramadan et puis c'est exactement mon nom
ils mangent du coup il est un peu la
dalle du coup il ne joue pas même au
pire pour être le tour et seront sous
perfusion a été battu tu prends tu
prends à manger et devant ton écran
j'étais convoqué mais je sais que
ramadan a passé aussi un moment familial
à toute la famille un peu trop loin en
fait tu ramènes taf admet fouet je veux
que les bons du coup on comptera sur
show pakistanais 107 personnes
la prochaine fois lundi le mois prochain
du coup du goût du bouquet ce qui se
passe dans cette partie que fait est que
fait midi tous ses pions halal dame
rouge et caïques où le cavalier le
cahier cloud et attention aux cavaliers
ne bouge pas aller automatiquement si tu
bouges la dame est derrière attention
voilà rockets qu'elle est toujours qu on
fait pas peut-être un petit des quatre
la faveur de ces quatre n'ont pas non
madoff proches de ted h3g can 10 h 3 3
kw h 5 et wettre des quatre à detroit
mais parce que le carillon l'a dit qu'il
était cloué est alors du coup il aurait
mieux valu ne pas prendre un vrai mieux
les prendre en direct h2 parce que sa
garde et de clouage donc c'était plus un
truc pénible à gérer pour les blancs et
en plus le chou était plutôt une belle
pièce cela bon ok bon nature de moins
avec les blancs bon je capte le rachat
mail rompent le père de foucauld
appellation menace g3 éventuellement g
3g 2 on encaisse le fou ça veut dire
qu'il est peut-être objets mais dit de
retourner avec le fouet la bouffe ou g5
après kawaii les deux caves à leucate et
tout d'un coup je veux jouer sur le tout
âge ouais mais bon ça après mais du coup
elle fout des six des cinq peut-être car
à lieusaint cas présent gagné un tempo
peut-être fou j'ai cinq ans maintenant
la pin up alors bouger c'est un cas les
boums bien joué et estime du coup sûr
cavaliers des cinq fabien attention le
piège d'un progrès ça skins game 1 de
nos habitués qu'on arrêterait habitude
très habitude trop habitués roga roga
roga roga rond là dix cavaliers t5 et ce
qui va le voir et kitchen il le vaut il
ne voit pas
je sais pas j'espère aller les paris
sont ouverts et ce qu'ils voient dans
prend des 5 ou pas tu dis non on espère
en oui il va jouer pas du coup caïds et
2 d'après toi projet il est jouable même
la dame prend des 50 ans l'orchis keen'v
là quand tu commences à réfléchir comme
ça ils le voient pas c'est fini si il
n'a vu oui vous le cavalier aller tout
reprend aussi dans l'esprit voilà je
passe sur soi très bon mais c'est dans
l'esprit bon hercules un ça va c'est
bien maintenant juste quel est des deux
films de vampires tu sacrifies à la
brute a bien dirigé vers le banc face on
est venu faire un petit fleuve si bon
mais j'aurais bien fait clavier deux
finales développement faudra regarder
les vidéos sur gary on attaque en
surnombre on la mène toutes les pièces
en attaque c'est un peu naïf quand même
hein enfin elle suggère par là là là
dessus il lui a envoyé deux sms trois
mails et quatre coups de téléphone je
vais faire ma tanger cette attention aux
médias
est-ce que tu as bien reçu mon message
c'était comment ce défaut nez et non
attends je te donne aujourd'hui on fait
les frais les français alors là il peut
faire cavaler g5 fab assez dommage
bach et gagne ouais je voyais ça il
était était pas mal quand contre le
petit allemand wagner
mais de peur du monde en fait il était
mal épilé tard monuc avait fait une
remontée à la baisse le nombre d'heures
il était mieux je pense que les gars
disparition du maso a perdu aussi bon
dans mado plus embêtante si je vais
compte qu'un mec assez faible 1 20m
relativement pour maso auparavant les
vrais donc du coup et ian schultz maurer
remette est très bien après le module
l'état plus de
quoi et au pire et gallo romain 30 ans
au début du match je pense que qu'est-ce
qui ne va l'emporter la fin il a fait
une fourchette là allez quoi alors
qu'ils oeuvraient tous les symptômes
drapeau suisse pour qui ce qui n'échappe
aux français pour mai 19 h
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe drapeau français qui
eux au nom non t'as pas le droit
t'as pas le droit de faire ça t'as pas
le droit il ya un pion gratuit fab
on revient cavaliers pro 6 est à près
d'1 point f5 et d'un match 7 matches
c'est fini non christie non ok mais il
n'a pas le droit de faire ça on leur a
posé de nouvelles donations que ce passé
pour qui ce qu'il en est
ce qu'on a vu des belles parties un peu
voilà il a tous craquer famin là il a
craqué le pantalon le slip l'aï la poêle
à mon avis un kiss kill je pense qu'il
est en train de se balader à poil non
mais franchement
alors quelle catastrophe et le coach est
ce ce que tu joues ton dieu play that
the stone age
je sais pas sur la malle tu vas tu
commences à as tu glisses la petite à
sillans attention do you tu nous montre
une nouvelle facette de tes compétences
ouais j'suis pas sûr que pour l'anglais
ça nous rendrait cette new show et ses
new faces et offre aux futurs
personality lien j'ai envie de dire john
newmark verica fuller de people chez ce
point comme cela je tenais donc c'est we
don't speak english and without mentent
jamais je veux dire un truc sur le blog
de fiona je parle en anglais bon ok mais
ça n'a aucun sens que je disais que
bahia elle va quand même monté gros
comme ça quoi bon sens trop de son camp
à la coupe et ils sont partis quand même
ça retravaillé pour l'anglais et là j'ai
fait mais je vais moto moto entraînez
vous savez faire un dvd
enfin un truc les vidéos peuvent aller
faire anglais français ouais donc j'ai
montré leur français optent dès que tu
cherches pendant que la yes it is my
norme c'est que j'ai tellement écouté h
quand j'étais jeune avec aimé césaire
non pas le nécessaire le philosophe paul
lemay 16 heures 2h il règle d'or sont
engagés les fantastiques et du coup je
parle très bien le langage direct judor
par exemple salalah ouais je suis bon là
l'esprit jazz animé français et
l'horrible il souffre aussi en français
c'est quelque part c'est ton cousin
anglais peut-être wicked pertes est tout
un petit cap à cap us open ouais ça
c'est assez cas pas là il va falloir que
tu ne bat pour être dans l'univers du
stream alors hhbc des qui a son son
compte diamant et c'est dommage il va
tomber mais était gagnant contre
quelqu'un qui à 400 points 4 400 points
de plus que lui est ce que le conte
diamant à jouer là dessus il faut qu'on
donne des cours de prix moment ouais ou
dessus car diamant suivi après la vidéo
pour bien jouer aux échecs
après non un peu du prénom qu'elle prend
il prévenu pas mal quand même
mais ce bonheur dans son ensemble
d'offres premium
il a perdu mais on sent qu'on me sentais
très bien vrai du mesquin aux joueurs
prévient quelque part à celador on avait
eu le bon flair a kiss kiss qui va
regarde c'est horrible il restait 0,6
face et qui si les diamants aussi mais
du coup ils représentent pas vraiment
les comptes bien monkey skins
il a représenté pendant un moment il est
vrai qu'elle est arrivée faut des deux
est un des diamants et commence à
représenter pourtant pourtant et
diamants sont éternels moi je sais pas
qui doit-on croire que ce passe-t-il
alors qu'ils qui suit on suit ton gros
chat contre killer maniaque et
l'armagnac en même pas mal classés bon
les gars est ce que est ce que c'est
chaud alors pour les master classes bon
là peut-être vous jouez en plus ne peut
pas trop répondre
on saisit écoutez vous pourrez pas en
revanche pour la masters cup dimanche
dans dimanche plus en objet dans l'envié
d'en parler dans la vidéo qu'on a fait
hier
ça va peut-être nous force à faire un
live demain avant de sortir au pub petit
heures on verra suivant comment la route
se passe de synthé à cannes
bon là on peut revenir se poser tu pars
acquérir 15 heures les armateurs je vois
jamais mené de pas me poser la gare
comme un taulier ce soit cool rage entre
5 et one two go blaquart de m tu peux
lui dire je mettrais 5,4 à son blabla
carrés avec m'ont conduit à manchester
comme j'ai créé une petite note sur
chaque point comme on préfère te dis
je t'achète même un pack de bières ont
construit bref bon qu'est ce que c'est
que ça bouchonne à gauche en fait ils
ces démunis en fait de son avis il ya il
s'est dit je ne veux plus de pièces sur
ces colonnes
je le sais voilà ça m'énerve c'est ça
qu'est bon du coup il peut être plus
concentré sur sa trop sur 5 8e du jeu un
peu plus que la moitié du jeu c'est une
bonne stratégie
non mais tu vois c'est si vous se
débarrasser de ses pièces la chasse est
peut-être un petit roc dames 8
bon ça tu le donnes tu sais pas comment
tu fais puis tu donnes tu t'organises
oui joue sur une moitié des chics et
petit tablier en fait tu consens 9
chrome os doit finir jouer costumes rage
pages de raconter vraiment au sucre plus
à d'amères haye où il veut il veut en
fait il veut des murs sont à son
adversaire aussi ses colonnes la il se
dit non toi non toi t'as pas le droit de
le remanier à lui valent aussi avec
ariane 5 a tant matériellement on en est
où il a connu une qualité de moins ou
chat mais c'est toujours ainsi c'est pas
si bien placé peut-être il peut essayer
de la chope et ouais je sais pas faire
ça me paraît un peu moche ça ces trucs
là non ouais ok soit vraiment beaucoup
mieux que je veux même pas qu'on la
tacle à tours jusqu'à dun dessin bref
être un peu créatif dame des sept tours
à cirque d'un v6 non mais donne des
soldats mais le système est bon j'étais
ici ça tu vas y à thouars à cinq
voitures y sont
pas si simple d'aller bouffer un peu
fourre et monsieur patate il a une tête
dosti rehman non
ouais c'est chez ce brass erawan parce
que c'est un simple chercheur a tu vas
tu as une chaise draghi aussi chez ce
drama tu vas y que mettre des deux
choses rares tables et chaises rade par
tout un peuple mais qui nous lie sorte
m'ont fait pas être seuls des tchats
bras ce monsieur le suivre wen ont fait
carrément abonnés faux faux leurs
fichiers numériques en fait de savoir
être de serre à wade cette dame
annabelle torrent à la tête de guiry tu
fais des têtes de partout tu es au
dessus tout le monde après et nous on
veut pas créer nos propres auteurs n'ont
pas encore il ferait qu'on soir par des
travaux
on veut des têtes de touvre après il
faut redire tête de pipe btu et elbeuf
calavon le moment pour l'équipe de
france tu trouves pas de joueurs sains
et lola non je songe acquis 6 9 a battu
alizé mes cavaliers f7 non mais tu as qu
est ce qui vous regarde et peut-être
malin la gauche à cette dame b2b de
s'arrêter plus sympa et puis il faut b5
après les franchises de partout vous les
foules pour vous remettre en ordre de
marche en marche par marche
les fous sont à la suit pas le mouvement
non plus tu as qui skinny il est en
avance sur son temps parce que tu allais
les autres joueurs j'aurais un peu
roland garros
du coup bon ça parlait un peu gasquet où
il vit tout ça gasquet via neuchâtel
longari vit en suisse tu as tout laitue
l'équipe de france de tennis sont tous
en suisse
quasiment alors que les joueurs de des
chèques non donc tu vois ce qui se dit
ni l'aurait été en avance les skins
précurseur
il aurait type il aurait pu être
précurseur et n'est d'ailleurs des
joueurs suisses n'habite pas en suisse
rogers est rarement suisse wawrinka
passait ensuite en ballerines caille
souvent en suisse
d'ailleurs wawrinka aller dans la même
salle de sport que robert fontaine pour
ça que c'est une ligne du grand chelem
au maroc
je pense même pas peut-être même c'est
sûr c'est ça me paraît évident stones
the man et tu vois il ya qui signifie je
viens de neuchâtel donc il revient
peut-être dans tes petits papiers pour
l'équipe de france qui ait ce qui est la
can qui il a quelques avantages à l'est
le fonds a eu qu'à gros chat allez-vous
remarque cpc nul parce qu'un essai 5
mais je sais pas à l'abattoir je bouffe
gouv qc ca ces câbles c'est faux car
séparés c'est sympa je viens de jouer ce
franco suisse est quoi la grâce c'est
camilla de co2 passe partout
il voit les deux beaux scores plus que
doit comme moi j'ai qu'un passeport non
aussi mais j'ai eu une carte de résident
en russie ça ça n'a pas de prix
ça c'est très très dur très très
difficile à obtenir y'a tobin qui nuance
de spectateurs d'un tournant les
spectateurs du tournoi
parce que si on était acteur c'est vrai
que fout on s'inquiéterait la dame à mon
avis n'a plus beaucoup de cases adam de
groucha donne mais mal c'est là qu'il
faudrait qu'ils limiteront polling ta
caisse aux torontois tué dans l'oeuf un
à un la réforme est plus qu'une blague
du coutier remania dame de plus allez on
va voir autre chose on va voir dans
l'esprit tient dans l'est
rien que dans l'esprit il veut faire
l'amour fou ces cartes aller il feinte
pour le vent lui être question de berre
où le sang à bien y avoir des sinistres
olympique échecs pour de monsieur bien
joué ça c'est dans l'esprit ça qu'on
veut voir
il va marquer son premier point alors
avoir une manuelle d'une garderie gaal
est allé et boum oui mais lien avec les
noirs bon j'ai quatre sont une option
comme pomme s'est consacré 9 4 caisses
de -16 2 - la zone maths c'est
inquiétant on a connu mieux comme on y
tombe humide 10 demain à la pendule
je pense que ça va peut-être aller voir
alors à prévoir hsbc déjoueront très
roots moeurs et des habitués hhbc il est
pas loin on commence que woods smurf
dans la zone 48 à l'esat bonne je suis
là je pense qu'il est dans les 10900
fidéen donc et hhbc des plus tôt dans
l'es13 150 à l'origine du concept où
tout reprendre sa gauche night avec 5
vous
bon c'est pas forcément meilleur coup
mais juste ok envie de faire diversion
aller et boum
il veut pas faire vous non parce que ton
mais se fait pas bon vous vous quel est
notre dame et saint flour 4 voilà avec
5.5 mais vous rend très mauvais goût
mais là il a montré qu'il était rapide
ouais le clic rapide a pas mal il
fallait pousser à direct mais c'est pas
mal joué on sent le premium on semble
prêt à mon sens on sent le membre
diamant la gamme a8 dame tu as contre
l'achat il va donner la dame compte
l'option tuera ou buzz et leur fait ses
choix
quant à lui aussi mais je vais faire
bref 5 et 6 bat par la belle fin de
partie alors on va peut-être voir
raphaël et rebif r b j contre al gran al
gran saison n'a jamais vu juste qui se
passe sur le chat ont une histoire
patate monde et tout laisse enfin un
truc mais pointu between goldman ce qui
est à rolle par l'icc sa connexion et
hautbois vinales il en fait ce métier tu
sais que ta roll et dans mon et dans mon
groupe de clash royal et le groupe il
est fantastique je sais pas si je peux
montrer aux gens les gens discutent sur
le seul chat attends je te dise qui
m'écrivent alors y'a pas de poules dont
celui d'un open on regarde ce que les
gens écrit sur le sur le coup je répète
un le groupe de clash royal donc y'a
rien avoir été échec il ya un mec qui
écrit allez on sort le hashtag va dans
le df donc déjà les mecs se faire
et c'est sûr que là je parle dans les
mecs je sais pas les mecs d'échec face à
des mecs qui sont plus évolués et y en
avait il écrit du coup on milite pour le
désistement des 100 premiers lots
français pour cave en edf aussi quoi du
coup en fait les mails sur clash royal
sont beaucoup plus chaud que les mecs
sur sur les sites déchets classiques en
ce choc
webb a bien sûr là ils sont réellement
dans le ton et j'ai bien aimé en fait le
hashtag vlad en edf je pense qu'on peut
lancer le hashtag et apprend montrera
blal ces normes est à l'essai depuis le
clash mais ils sont chauds et du coup il
m'a quand même demandé un cochon après
il m'a dit oui on voit moins une carte
cochon du coup j'ai envoyé une carte
cochon quoi mérite sa carte il mérite
des cochons comme quoi tu vois en fait
peut-être qu'en se lançant donc là je
croyais en arrêtant les trucs d'échec un
peu tête tu vois tu apprendras à venir
on va toucher un nouveau public en fait
un public sera bien plus intéressés par
les échecs qui va partager des trucs des
chaînes sur sur facebook est partout
emmanuelli a fini grisha ne joue pas ça
lui de jouer alors oui gauche à
montchaude déjà une mouche à quelque 15
euros alors où elvis elle miss est ce
qui s est lui c'est encore là ah oui
c'est parti ce ne sera pas le premier
devises allez tu vas voir elvis demain
en plus c'est hyper méga show ici aussi
qui coule hockey est roi c'est pas trop
l'esprit du tmb 5 du tour c'est un des
trucs très actif mais bon ok les thèmes
du jeu pour rappel jean - mais bon la
paire de foule le projet doit ses
puissants candidats connaissent la
théorie non du coup tu penses que vous
qu'on se lance van khache royal quoi que
d'audience plus plus de trucs on pourra
faire des stages mark ii
de classe royale commerçants
participants des choses comme ça après
le sage normal pour lancer notre seul
gros succès j'ai pas mal de participants
il ya très très peu de place il reste
très peu de place pour le symptôme d'un
bon mot tant mieux oui oui non et tant
mieux mais bon c'est juste celui-ci en
fait je resterai très peu de casse en
fait là c'est déjà et en plus son nom
paul quoi c'est pas juste un truc
commercial chez vous ou pas tomber deux
mais bon on fait semblant
non là pour le coup on s'approche 10-12
quoi on s'apprête à petit tapis on est à
petit mais cinquième masters class
souhaite pas de grands succès même à 5
mai mais bon les gens peut-être pas on
verra revoir un ça va prendre ça à fond
le bouche à oreille mayonnaise
voilà le bouche à oreille le tam tam tam
tam le cri la fenêtre à cri la fenêtre
peut-être que comme ça on va y arriver
mais ne compte pas trop sur facebook
c'est mon goût segment balawi j'ai cru
comprendre qu'on avait très peu de
facebookeurs la peña si on en gros clash
royal en revanche à la fête a
pratiquement on est dans l'esprit les
bris de châssis n'en peut plus jean
françois bay qingming mais mange quoi
buzz et c'était très bon le bilan de la
rui c'est quand même deux défaites et
une nulle mais je pense que c'est parce
que je suis passé dans l'esprit des
slaves nba face b c d il veut regagner
un deuxième un deuxième avant diamant le
sens il salua plus il est il à fond
regarde devant votre regarder jouer une
ruine sur futuriste à la prochaine on te
suivre ouais ouais je sais aidera les
bons est normalement je préfère les
bruits ce côté noir pour plus dans
l'esprit
un univers qui que le brochage ou et
donc du coup ça nous intéresse que se
passe-t-il deux espaces de manioc ligne
acquise et groucha année par la bouche
est arrivé mais mais se faire raser un
peu la même époque il y avait cette
course fait route qui d'un coup de patte
magique revient dans la partie de ces
gens qui me disent que tu viens encore
en russie
lemmings suit thanksgiving à l'acte un
ton jeu capcom annonce un ca sommes
beaucoup de potes aussi afin d'amuser 3
bien je vais chez le boucher est quand
même
et coup de griffe à vif par ci par là et
vous faire fouet cette voiture est
peut-être dû prendre ton chat avec toi
il sera présenté à elvis monsieur je
veux pas le perdre
bref ça après si tu dire tu peux tu
décline toute responsabilité sur ses
pages aux chocs
je ne veux rien avoir à faire avec cela
et c'est que le soir je rentrais chez
moi on était sortis on était sorti avec
ma femme je rentre chez moi genre vers
minuit minuit et demi qui je croise dans
la rue et lui il était là quand il était
sorti aussi est ok il est venu boire un
peu de lait chez moi et puis il est
parti j'avais aimé yaoum héros c'est
fantastique
allez je te lis sacrifie tout lé gros
chat fais nous plaisir
l'étoile suis fait un petit signe
goodwin où il nous parle ans miley pour
essayer d'être devant internationale
malins les six briche un peu plus de sa
main gauche mais d'autres ont fait il ya
plein de têtes de troupes
oui mais la tête car pour chaque tête me
dis un truc que oui peut-être qu'apple
veut dire quoi
mais un cas pas chez plus en fait je
savais mais c'est plus oublié mais bon
c'est un peu hilarious quoi c'est un peu
il a tu peux faire des caps add par ce
week-end en fait un cas pas on fait un
nous aussi des fans de pop up c'est la
rieuse quoi ouais enfin le capteur là
j'écris cas pas en fait le tour du globe
les pick-up vraiment peu c'est quand tu
trolles gâchage les cdi connais mieux
tout mais ouais c'est un peu du trolling
ou à tancer mittal et je vais essayer
mais redoutent beaucoup plus au fait des
airs gardien regard regarde il faudra
essayer de faire tout reprend j'ai deux
dames g4 essayer de faire un père pète
classe si la dame ce bar branché de in
check roi prend est d'alger 4 way
nul pas trop prudent trop prudent allez
payer boon panne au psg 2-1 bouchotte à
cinq secondes façon salon où l'invention
du tombe
qu'est ce que j'explique mon nom mais là
c'est tombé et prochain tour murray del
potro et 7 commence à être un peu
intéressante il va se faire défoncer
mari mais je suis pas si del potro et
toutes leurs établissements continuent
non mais vraiment c'est pas non plus
alors guillaume guillaume vigneault
raout ce nom biomarine mal à 120 ans on
m'a du couloir
attention c'est à 15
richard gasquet qui est en train de se
balader un monde qui joue estrella
l'étoile quoi ci par là espagnol
bon bah table as ta place comme des 13
autres pas l'imposition il ya 4 x 5 x 6
x vous cette fois la même position
nouvelles règles du jeu je dis que j'ai
gagnés par multi répétition de huit fois
nouvelle ré avec la fidh et pour ceux
qui aiment des animes je vous conseille
koné colleau cash carthage est récent et
très bien avec de beaux messages
infectés konopka patcher bataille de
faire un accent japonais ont excusé
c'est être complètement à terre inconnue
tiens à partie qu'on a quitté tout à
l'heure a le grade qui se bat bien des
films d'animation a précédé sa nuée
défense arménien à quoi bon ok ok on
fera passer le mot qui pour les fans moi
je suis pas vous la patronne sommes
nulles bout la suisse mène qu'on soit à
dire russie 1-0 à neuchâtel quel sport
football
bonjour c'est nécessaire c'est du foot
ça est très difficile un crédit bishop
suis pas très bon en imitation japonaise
j'imite plutôt en fait les inconnues qui
imite s'imitent les bioman pour ceux qui
connaissent mais bon c'est une autre
génération c'était une génération
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on suit qu'est-ce
qu'on suit est ce qu'il ya des gens
qu'on n'a pas suivi encore du tout wesh
alors 735 mais je sais que la nati j'ai
des bons joueurs
un jouet à sainté lacroix défenseur
central maintenant pour il n'a pas trop
joué cette année mais peut-être sera pas
mal puis avec le changement d'entraîneur
à voir mais nos vies donc je pensais que
la suisse attend une belle équipe on les
a souvent croisé avec l'équipe de france
on gagne et jamais nous doutons 0 0 donc
et puis les biélorusses en fait on me
prenait pas trop mais il règle m une
fois n'est perdu contre calife haroun du
monde un truc à domicile c'est enfin à
dire très marrant ce policier une partie
de mort fille avec les noirs assez
connue par ses positions
bah ouais mais sonne mais ces points
noirs sont bonnes mains c'est très bien
pour les noirs en fait ouais tu peux
faire des cinq structures c'est ça est
encore plus fort
rodman ou quatre noms alors un point au
classement
mais emmanuel ignore qui a combattu le
secret 82 ans je n'arrive pas à
retrouver le classement en fait je suis
en plein dans le but c'est d'être au
second poteau
j'ai un bug feu partout et classement
est bon en tout cas il se bat ce cri 94
il a deux sur trois contre massages deux
sur trois on n en sait pas encore en
cours pour l'industrie mobile
alors gare de voir les transferts 3 seul
en tête
c'est en fait trop de sodium vinetot
maîtresses avec deux demis et après
après le peloton pas de surcroît le pont
ni par émail guignard midi zollitsch 83
mo l'e-mail yasen max hoff ce que 94 qui
leur manie attendu treize noms eva et sa
mclaren
donc attention un beau groupe i et puis
on est bon il est l'heure il souffre en
souffrance qu'on devait mal tourner
arthur ce qui libérera l'audience est
donc à plus de vingt joueurs actifs
domptant ouais les autres sont fait
reprendre par la voiture balai il ne
s'était pas dans les délais fab 2 tours
de retard alors aussi un autre qui est
important que je vais être une première
fois dans le choc mais la chaîne la
chaîne youtube chez ce point comme fab
faut qu'un moyen bon rhume au moins
important que la chine bitstream n'est
qu'un ingénieur c'est vrai il faut quand
même en parler
donc du coup parce qu'en fait les
replays de tout ce qu'on fait sur twitch
va sur la chaîne j'espère comme français
faut le savoir
dis donc ouais mais comme c'est très
très intéressant la pédagogie du coup je
mets un lien voulez vous abonner
ça vous va
on peut partager non je rigole partager
à peut-être fois je crois à l'eswc
attaque un flash traille et le g5 dans
un piège comme ça qu'on joue à célébrer
ici un des rares voix bas il aimerait
gagner quelques parts non tu mérite de
gagner si tu as des pièges club ça ah tu
mérites fabien tu aimes content de
t'avoir petit à petit initiaux vrai
échec quand même j'ai l'impression
depuis depuis depuis maintenant un an tu
commence petit à petit quand même abattu
à avoir des réflexions plus intéressant
dit ma foi chose le jeu tu dis plus il
ya cavaliers j'ai cinq sapeurs diront si
la cie le voit il a mérité de gagner tu
vas tu es plus tu vois de plus en vue
réaliste en fait dans ta vision du jeu
et ça tu le sens nantes est partie en
réel je pense quand tu rêves je sens que
j'ai franchi un palier
sinon bravo à tous ceux qui ont joué
contre moi je suis surpris du niveau
proposé car pas très fair nul grâce au
temps contre 1 2050 fidh à l'écran est
automatiquement c2050 fils les gens
doivent sans difficulté non mais
s'ajoute pas même sans doute pas mal là
les gars c'est bien non je ne joue pas
mal on remarque souvent quand on va et
simultanée ou les machins sagem mtg
message ou non il joue très bien mais
pour pour faire crédit bishop's le
joueur contre qui a fini lâchage bcdc un
mezze live et il joue en fait assez bien
en fait ils jouent vraiment assez bien
il n'est pas très bien classés parce
qu'il est très jeune mais il est assez
doué et il joue vraiment bien en fait et
du coup ça m'étonne pas il peut faire
des très bonnes parties de temps en
temps fait des parties d'entraînement de
temps en temps et il peut tout beau être
bon il peut pas me battre mais il est
pas mal ce que tu vois je n'ai pas
appris à faire des pièges quoi tu vois
ce que je veux dire
d'abord il faut je crois ben en fait
j'ai appris vraiment à jouer aux échecs
on n'a pas fait vous on n'a pas vraiment
à prix d'ouverture ni rien donc qui
galérait un peu dans les catégories
jeunes tout ça parce que c'est pas
toujours facile mais en fait
enfin du coup il a des vrais échecs en
fait cela sans rigoler pour la peine
là je parle sérieusement du coup
on apprend des vraies choses en fait et
il peut vraiment pas ma joue en fait
peut vraiment faire des bonnes parties
genre il peut faire des bonnes slave en
fait par exemple ce qui est assez
étonnant pour un jeune
en plus il est sympa du coup voir leur
fable iv piège on tente ici mais j'ai
pas trop objective à l'ip du coin devant
son binôme tête d'âne au cynisme touche
pas mais en fait il s'est raté enfin la
partie en plus je la connais il s'est
complètement raté
max roche n'a fait absolument n'importe
quoi nous avons ok c'est pas sourd
simple oubli 200 m dames aussi sa
patronne des gares d'improbables pourpre
encaissé 5
c'est un peu plus de ce retour est vite
notre terrain prend 17 sinon ouais mais
bon ok moi même ça va pas dis moi c'est
quelques pièces
hier je pense que la surprise de demain
à roland garros ce sera la victoire de
zeballos contre goffin ouais ouais j'ai
un peu vu jouer là sur terre battue
zeballos de trois tournois et il a
vraiment pas mal joué les femmes et que
la tension s'enregistrer toussaint mais
je pense que ça peut être la grosse
surprise est goffin il m'impressionne
pas trop en fait mais bon on fait un
chèque qui joue bien mais il me rappelle
un peu rochus notre benji way rappel de
rochus
ouais parce qu'on cette partie du coup
alors on en est là sinon je peux s'est
vu magnus que jouer en simultané contre
comme kevin ce pays si j'ai vu une photo
du matin quatre coups
mais ok parole quoi je vais te dire que
les cabines sont nuls non bon très chaud
cette hausse découle cauchemar pour mes
mains des stars attaquer mais les échecs
et puis et puis en plus il le retour de
house of cards sortie quand marc n'ai-je
pas saison 5 sur netflix et tu regardes
homeland alors je regarde j'ai lâché le
choix ça nul mais il paraît que c'est
remonter en puissance et que ça nous
vaut bien alors peut-être souffraient
les femmes mais j'ai vraiment c'était
trop tard et j'ai dû faire trois saisons
qui chipotent la 4ème et saoulé j'ai
raté mon court 3e où je sais plus
d'ailleurs et encore 3e ce que c'est la
troisième qui était pas bien j'ai fait
un truc comme ça j'ai lâché 1 mais j'ai
entendu beaucoup de bien de celle là est
ma série préférée silicon valley tu
regardes ou pas non elle est fantastique
cette série il se passe quoi
dans cette partie civile c'est un peu
bizarre ce que du coup il y avoir un fou
de couleurs opposées mais moi il ya
tellement de pions 1
mais bale gagnant pour les blancs mais
bon c'est un peu technique mais avec
lebron james en les tournant cet organe
et mes arrêts clés tour d'autant plus et
donc j'ai pas simple de décès de hadja
court mais bon ok y'a qu'un second
combres eure va te finir alors un jeu
prison break saison 5 et manuel guignard
j'ai lâché prise à vrais copains aussi
mais en fait si les lâcher en même temps
que vlad en fait la ddt
on a le même point de vue sur prison
break c'est que prise en préservant son
parti de sortie de prison ferme huawei a
évidemment game of thrones qui va
redémarrer pas quelle saison on n'est
d'ailleurs pas cinq ou six comme ça
lorsque luc dehors de sa nouvelle la
prochaine avec la mère des dragons jones
dans une note
john snow se passer du coup il vous
avertit remonte reste encore deux roues
il reste encore de rebondir est plus que
18 joueurs la voiture balai fait effet
du mal à suivre audeval contre euro
money mais non les a pas encore suivi
mon email qui nous vient à fortiori de
madagascar entre est banni max nous dit
que c'est shôjo pas de souligner qu'ils
adorent et du skate jones et du caïd ge
sur un net repli
et bah j'ai tout regardé
moi je suis gardé mais je peux
comprendre je ferai pas le temps que la
droite chica jones et d'ailleurs tous
les réunir je crois en fin d'été mais
les défendeurs jessica jones et pas du
coup l'udc edge daredevil et s'appelle
et iron fist les quatre uniques on ne
sait pas quel ni maléfique
il aura un truc comme ça salut super
grimpeur qui vient d'arriver sur le
tchat
en habitué aussi un habitué des stream
donc du coup tu as netflix qui est moi
ouais ouais
est-ce que tu as eu une des séries
préférées de vlad the wire non mais j'en
ai entendu du bien de ça j'avais un
élève qui qui met beaucoup avec musique
c'était super est-ce que tu as au moins
vu la scène quand ils apprennent à jouer
aux échecs
non je pense que je connais absolument
pas je n'ai rien vu beaucoup d'occasions
ce qu'en fait la scène est hyper connue
des sonos votre mobile bon je regarde
pas mais non là cette scène n'a pas trop
vieilli parole qui nie kiev n'a pas
parlé du clan clash royal si j'en ai
parlé tard elle pointait la coupure
d'électricité cie n'a pas fini on a
parlé en très bien que je sais pas je
vous connais pas je suis fier de mon
quoi le clan voulant céder hashtag fait
des trucs c'est exactement ce que je
vois qui se passe avec la chaîne beats
crise les gens qu'ils soient là que le
board des attaques de partout qui met un
peu de la folie quoi complètement dingue
sur ce clan il reste pas mal grotte du
mas venir mais je pense que tu vas tu
vas bientôt si tu vas jouer
bah ouais vraiment fait le problème
c'est que je suis hyper dit il faut que
demain comme ça quoi donc je préfère un
otage ou et du tout que mm parce qu en
fait j'étais super nul mais j'aime pas
être nulle et un truc maintenant je le
suis toujours le même de quelqu'un tu
gardes
ok j'aime pas de super nul tenu le tout
le monde est ok du cou à force on te dit
passer du temps et puis bah du coup fait
pas autre chose qui rate est plus
intéressant et puis puis à prévoir mais
après j ai rejoint sans heurts du coup
j'ai raté mon été bon voila comme vous
voulez pas savoir ce qui permet moment
en tout cas je suis en train d'ouvrir un
coffre magique pour ceux qui jouent je
reçois un coffre magique qui sera ouvert
dans 12 heures jusqu'au jusqu'au choix
n'ont pas encore là et j'aurai déjà le
coffre magique ouvert et qu'est-ce que
tu pouvais sur un terrifiant dit si bien
de nola rice qui nous parlent de leur
histoire effectivement j'ai beaucoup
apprécié intéressante oui oui 30 à son
symétrique il blanc peut-être un peu
mieux j'ai pu faire du caillou 5 et 6
mai laurence était léger pieuvre il ya
une possibilité de pieuvre les
tentacules nf3 qui sont en train de nous
donc bien quelqu'un venu au 5 mai mois
plus tôt mais l'autre mais pas vrai
qu'on écoute face à la crise et c'est
juste ça crée du jeu fini sa joie en
cachette c'est surtout que je lisais les
messages pour récupérer leur style mais
peut-être que les génies du clan ont
peut-être tenté d une voiture d nouveau
hashtag en fait à le chien n'est pas
content d'avoir sur quatre cas d'accord
des jouets 300 400 heures en vrai mais
c'est ça que j'ai pas ce genre de choses
par nous mais je sais que je suis
complètement capable
de pierre j'ai fais quand je vais au big
blind j'ai raté pas d'y jouer avec
consoeur tablette ou quoi non mais c'est
jacques doodle jump quoi déjà un moment
de l'hymne je sautais partout va c'est
pas pour moi c'est je vois donc mal en
plus d'autant plus si le jeu est
vraiment bien ça va être terrible qua
non mais ce qui est bien c'est qu'en
fait tva une vite bloqué par les cartes
en fait je veux acheter les cartes mais
ça va coûter très très cher
j'ai fait un peu des calculs pour
vraiment voir toutes les cartes il faut
plusieurs milliers d'euros
bah écoutez les gars du coup le tipi
plus du tout pour des blogs par des
échecs % s'en fout on va acheter les
cartes et du taf on fera des ducs ou des
vidéos de sa meute est pas mal en fait
c'est quoi en fait on s'en fiche un peu
qu'on sache était belle caméra quoi se
développe deux tournois bon il ya
d'autres le font quoi alors que des
joueurs d'échecs jouant un clash machin
et tout le monde
le pire ces essais the binding of isaac
je connais pas ce jeu où j'ai passé mis
200 heures avant que l'on perd
supprimons conditions c'est génial que
1200 heures
j'avais lu un truc c'est genre sont
interdits miller dans un truc de haut
niveau d'expertisé de la 1200 heures tu
es sur la bonne voie peut-être que je
sert absolument à rien fait et je valide
son père qui arrivent et doit être en
pls
moi je suis pris ma retraite en fait à
l'aise parole de pauvres auraient dû
faire une vidéo youtube mon père avons
perçu prix
alors à une secte pour roland tiers en
obtiennent j'ai un autre thème mais bon
si c'est ma team chez tony team non à la
question sur rolland s'est rendu aux
cornes djoko en fait à nadal nadal
ouais mais quelque part les deux
questions sont lire en fête because
images à lise nadal djoko might blanche
who knows 1 j'ai envie de dire parce que
murray very bad forme d'apports rogers
il peut se passer n'importe quoi ça ne
m'intéresse pas vous ne m'aurez pas
cette année les croulants
ne comptez pas sur moi pour analyser
tout ça quelques résidus celle ci n'est
que tous les jeunes jouer à clash royal
en sortie du tournant en ile de france
il faut il joue vrai échec en fait ces
vents comme ce que je veux dire on me
carle a répondu patrick et le parti et
du bois mais d'échelle c'est comme
plants versus zombies
en fait il a une position c'est un peu
les plâtres sa partie à carling cup il
se faisait attaquer partout s'occupant
17e les ombilicaux qui arrive est ok
quoi tu me plains tu craches des trucs
du métier qui leur piquent les pieds
d'el en slave
tu trouve toutes les ressources que tu
peux pas pour t'accrocher sauver ta vie
quoi mais voilà quoi
il est compris que c'était une bonne
référence mais nous en revanche dans les
commentaires de notre chaîne youtube ça
passe pas toujours très bien ce genre de
référence
tu parles plus d'échecs l'attention non
non non ça s'appelle tu fais tu fais
8600 vidéos gratuites qui dit une fois
une blague mais non mais faire mal à
tout jamais non non c'est nulle part
d'échecs et forme les attentats tard à
lui franchi les tua il dit
je me passais mon cochon au niveau 8
gilles avec son copain hashtag paye ton
cochon saljic
[Rires]
et attention malik willem il et il aime
pas trop del potro
moi j'aime bien del potro
ça peut être la carte à gratter là bas
mais ok pas peut-être même pas son style
de jeu un peu trop bu seront pas trop
tard trop forte elle s'installe on n'y
pense jamais fait mais la menace acquis
à cancun est trop grand chelem
mais quand il est en forme il enfin donc
mais surtout qu'il a gagné assez
facilement aujourd'hui encore je
compterai qui joue et on encaisse aussi
renault gagne c'est quoi peut-être pas
depuis le spa nominale
je saïs l'absurde jarre mais bon après
le vrai cap est un sportif ou pas fait
payer qui va trop jarretelles plus
lumineuse attend donc thème que les
joueurs français en fait du beau frère
rajan pendant quelques jours s'agisse
pas là mais ici ça c'était comme
d'autres mots poloff pour pas facile
d'un nouveau pool of match piège
dangereux dans les copeaux la musique un
peu plus doux larry smith au toupet
d'assinie nous dit tout être allé voir
ça mais il a déjà perdu en fait bon
battant regardons la fda prochaine que
tu joues et on on commande tout ça mais
on est en forme ce soir un truc en en
forme
ouais il a non seulement se savonne sur
youtube de stream pendant une semaine
que wes annonces en ligne puis de deux
plages surtout dans une pluie de plage
je comprends pas ouais c'est pas faux
alors explosion les cieux la grosse
partie je pense que là dans l'esprit
contre hsbc décès la partie du truc
alors qu'est passage à huy b6 direct
push bon de la super des fois en ghetto
de tous les côtés là les enfants réfuté
la dans l'esprit il se dit mince heroes
le feu il regrette ses coûts de 4 et des
cathédrales
qu'ai-je fait pour mériter ça quoi à
quatre membres à 601 plus du moins
gotham dont ils laissent faire un cercle
à ruiz faut la jouer mais lors des coups
contre bâle et ça c'est pas si simple
life riz cuit jouer b5 en fait ouais du
coup il ya six cordes
donc tu assures à six tubes on va le
flou faut qu'ils rentrent chez lui bon
au pire c'est pas si grave
ouais mais bon il est moins bruyant -
ruiz en mai faut surtout pas dans celle
ci si on s'enfermait ok le flou et
rentrer chez vous alors voilà du coup un
simple salut sauve un peu son fou mal
joué les contres dangereux
je pense également eu envie de faire des
trucs comme ça j'arrête les lots phares
comme une estonienne maintenant après
cinq côté nord font payer 5 pouces et 6
qui avait fait 5 va être que mais bon
tant pis
donne ton ndam matin
qu'est ce qu'une ruse je suis fait
dégommer attention ballack et la russe
s'est quand même pas si simple des rangs
rigole en différentes briques dessus
mais mais bon faut qu'on dépasse pas six
étrangers en général on fait des
troubles à droite à gauche un peu mal se
passe c'est pas évident à jouer en fait
l'homme cette souffrance et 3,5 là comme
ça suit débarrasse du fou et faire
attention mais quatre qui enfin les
cadets enfermé pour un rôle où la ruine
à temps il parcourt faire un tournoi
spécial aubrystes grave et gombe ya des
cons en d'autres occasions mais pas ce
soir non stop dans la semaine du coup je
suis anti ruiz par principe mais moi
j'ai des résultats exceptionnels avec la
remise en fait donc façon de la jouer en
temps 12 l'année prochaine ces annonces
et les cessions dans le top-12 y aura
forcément une église c'est obligatoire
la super grimpeur est pris par les
combattants
mais d'ailleurs de sortir un livre le
montrer
moi je préfère la ruine je préfère dire
whisky potable veut dire que
ruissellement français non mais ruiz ces
liens tiger moderne c'est envoyé bon
c'est un nid de taïga il a personne de
remettre quelqu'un de rejouer d'ici à 6
tout ça avec eux faire beau pavé et il
peut faire un chapitre entier sur
l'arize bon qui a eu lui aussi la boxe
thaï rowbotham peu comme moi qu'au début
mais on n'avait pas le bon début a enfin
dit au potager à la cheville roots
marques comme les sur le chat est rare
ce qui fait boum
vous avez obtenu ce que dit à g a pas
mal moi trouve ouais j'sais pas si je
vois mais votre truc sur l'écran pour
voir si le vois de temps je vais voir si
vous voliez aux hôtes ils peuvent voter
utile et la hâte en ligne ou pour lupopo
terminus est donc bon ben il dit quoi du
coup belgique et d'hippopotamus bon que
beau lit ça fait chier grave potable du
coup il va plus à l'ipo de valider mieux
vaut changer non et redone ont évité de
voter après je dis non en fait non du
coup au mieux non qui dit c'est pas
tellement dingue c'est plus un système
dit qu'on peut avoir ça dans vos
différentes lignes flexibles de la
moderne sur la voie classique sur le
flexible dragon jamaïque ou g5 solinhac
h3 et lady voilà donc j'ai l'impression
que vous l'avoir fait il montre le truc
avec a6b 6 dé 6,6 g 6 h 6 des deux
chevaux de l'endroit la dame le sujet ça
le foot 17
comme on peut le voir il y pose cash
flow quoi
hypo lives of the water il clocks aux
lois sur les liqueurs eastleigh passive
amélie trichet considère ces hypothèses
et bio peaceful almost milk animal mais
il dit il ya rien n'est plus loin que la
vérité de la vérité que ça coûte depuis
prés l'animal et la position et
statistiques tout ça tout change qu'on
me dit que c'est une bête féroce prête
un massacre et n'importe qui trop proche
des exceptions des ciseaux 6 qui étaient
là toutes les bouffeurs de cannes car
c'est un poète
voilà et explique ça tout ça après
arrête aussi la bonne paye la mauvaise
hip hop et victoire commence en occupant
une position sous la surface de l'eau en
gros tu es là tu reste cool dans l'eau
c'est là c'est bien sûr garder un oeil
sur ton adversaire et il sent que les
gens ont les mains libres à tard steven
il dit ok les lampes faire genre de
choses donc là tu as le diagramme qu'on
avait vu on dit ouais bon chez classique
moderne les fossés trek en fait voilà
dit ok les blancs atteint le paradis du
développement mais qu'est ce qui peut
faire ensuite
oui dit sinon le temps de le dire qu'ils
ont quelconque davantage aux initiatives
ils vont devoir franchir la barrière
quoi nous faire avancer un peu plus et
là je dis c'est chiant ce n'est plus un
noir contre le tout et du coup les cte
avance
attention il dit voilà il dit s'ils en
font foi fier tu peux t'attendre à 6,5
s'ils ont eu trois ans d'attenté des
cinq ligues en là on réagit donc ferme
quoi sur des singes ont fait aux 5 par
mois je trouve qu'ils parlent quand même
beaucoup la pologne - oui la tête par
les maladies qui s'est mise il se penche
sur le destin deviennent machin et mais
il est assez content et puis tout le
monde des partis ou en faites pas ça
marche très bien pour la norme
donkey lasserre avis est-ce qu'une
conclusion chapitre ouais mais j'aime
bien son histoire d'animal sous l'eau et
tout pas même ses impôts mais oui c'est
vrai les bons chasseurs quoi est-ce que
le chasseur et white ra solide chez
l'homme n'est que du coup elle apprend
leur est d'ailleurs sûrement classique
il recommande la vente de tir pierre
avait ou dû te trompes en fait avec toi
car elle te dis bon t'as un comprimé ce
pas plutôt revenir conclusions dit très
agaçant nico tu vas attaquant il
s'appelle super gars jeune mélissa
marche pour des amis dans les open
quand tes amis tu peux le faire donc toi
tu peux plus le faire déjà attention
toi tu as perdu l'appellation est mis
j'ai toujours ils ont mis une note
devant mais c'est pourtant empêché de
faire l'ipo ne pouvait être que ce qui
est supérieur faire c'est que c'était
illégal à partir niveau quand m faites
moi j'ai encore le droit de la jouer
doublement et d'abonder eux
j'ai fait un peu de lecture tout ça mais
bon je pensais que ça valait le coup
voir l'avis d'un expert sur l'ipo risque
est ce qu'on a déjà vu une partie des
deux joueurs qu'on l'arvise barrette ya
un problème parce qu'on tue b3 b6 loubet
de fouet c'est des canaux petites choses
dont j'en passe automatiquement tu perds
ta tour donc elle a peut-être que acier
mais ils ont eu des problèmes je veux
dire les mecs qui nous conseille de
jouer la civilisation 5 c'est vrai qu'on
pourrait jouer à civilisation 5 avec toi
je pense qu'on serait pas mauvais alors
moi je préfère la jouer en ligne pour
pour jouer contre eux alors je vous
recommande à tout le monde de regarder
le lady pelé narratif de de joueur du
grenier sur sur civilisation 5
c'est juste excellent sur youtube vous
tapez joueur du grenier
let's play narratif et civilisations 5
vous allez trouver c'est fantastique
si nous laissons 5 donc the bright il
sait pas trop comment ça c'est
intéressant bon s'exerce et exotique
mais pas plus supernova tue pas le jeu
de tête n'ont pu surtout les systèmes
mais éventuellement jab l'otan
donc ok super gaffeur et me dis donc
bataille tiger il a joué ou wim anciens
joueurs comme alex vol
il y en a un autre ouais je sais qui tu
parles si même en a parlé avant-hier sa
maman ouais c'est un grand maître
allemand
silverlight a introduit les belges paris
vous choquer d'avant d'or d'auplata on
sait qu ils jouent des fonds en france
grenoble et toulouse henry s'en fiche
sylvain m'a dit qu'il avait tout le
temps sauf contre lui et il fait des
super bien préparés en plus il avait
joué la ligne que toi tu jours ont
préparé ton truc qu'elle vient de faire
un truc que tu m'as est recommandé doit
aussi un du plus c'est ce qu'ils avaient
préparés et ils manient et le mec d4 d5
cobras royaux ben stiller magna qui a
gagné devant guillaume vinh et windsurf
donc bras avoir acquis leur manière et
du goût killer maniaci gagne en
abonnement ou pas bon c'est pas parce
qu'on tue pensons bien qu'hier manière à
travers un peu regardé son compte
on va un peu en un peu rugueuse 25 août
2013 il est membre depuis longtemps sur
czech comme il ya sont allés en lausanne
france art pourquoi l'aurait on va on va
contacter avant d'assurer qu'il est
notre hub morceaux n'intéresse que s'il
n'a pas le temps ou quoi mais si ça
m'intéresse il ahmed désole gagner sinon
on peut donner un cadeau du tournoi
alors qu'il peut nous écrire tout de
suite en fait si les la cité la killer
magna dans le chat de twitch sinon
bio julien de m'inscrire sur twitter à
ok il mérite donc on va s'occuper de ça
dont killer magna je vais noté ça je
vais noté ça et ça va être toi qui va
être le grand vainqueur le mérite tu
l'as mérité way et du coup tu pourra
tester tu commences tu étais chaise
comme diamant nuire à ce que tu en
penses tu peux suivre les médias sociaux
se tient à tanger le jour même
enfin les mecs là franchement moche et
que vous n'avez pas facebook 1 mais ça
on a quelque part on a compris mais pour
ce qu'ils ont fait ce bouquin n'hésitez
pas à suivre
voilà quelque part j'ai envie de dire ni
te beek oui merci pour pour le tournoi a
plus à peut-être le rapprochement fin 3
960 pourquoi pas elle a du coup je veux
bien jouer
non mais je serai pas long feu bon
d'être là on rejoint la semaine on a pu
faire pour 960 on vient jeudi prochain
peut-être peut-être
bah oui très bien y es tu arrivé au
caire il a bien profité de l'absence de
basse et bishop itou c'est vrai aussi
aimé être là au bon moment il faut
savoir se faufiler il exploite une
opportunité comme je le soufre s'offre à
nous c'est un peu comme roland garros
sans rogers 10 et invite apple pour le
tournoi aller pourquoi pas en langue
arabe celle ci veut jouer avec nous tu
as ils sont contents pour les neuf cent
soixante balais jeudi prochain 960 allez
c'est décidé
allez hop c'est parti c'est par ces
sauts vicieux mais essayer de jouer le
jeu je vais remettre un truc sur
facebook
les mecs on essaie âgées elle est comme
vous pouvez
si vous allez dis quoi c'est bien que
son marathon et 50 ou quoi c'est cool
c'est plus de georges les mêmes ça
commence à faire un truc c'est ce que
j'ai à dire que mme harel quoi tu sais
combien une partage au final bas un nom
00 pas de l'oeuf
peut-être quand même sur les 100
personnes présentes ce soir un qui à
facebook que je sais pas je me suis je
demandé à bâle 0 qui ont fait ce qu'il
veut partir et les potes qui savent
jouer ça c'est bien bravo merci très
bien et avec ce soit pour ce tournoi là
mais même un peu pour les vidéos vers
youtube tout ça quoi je veux dire parce
que ce serait super ce serait très sympa
il est temps de nous quitter
il est temps de nous quitter bonjour je
viens de me maintenir des parts à ce
qu'ils n'ont pas été notées 1 c'est
possible mais je n'ai pas partagé
attention les manuels dommage non mais
voilà maintenant c'est trop tard mais
une autre là elle a dû vous ne partagez
pas ici dans sa scène fait plus sens
mais partagée pour le truc que vous
verrez passer
c'est vrai que j'aime beaucoup votre
idée si je ne parle pas souvent merci ce
bras merci j'écris pamphlet bamako
contrat ou se voient cette 7ème art en
soi on n'a pas trop parlé chèque mais
y'a des vidéos sur la chaîne qui sortent
et puis on verra les master classes et
tout ça donc vous inquiétez pas on
n'oublie pas non plus des fois de paris
chic et choc mais je pense que les
scream du jeudi soir en général c'est
pas vraiment fait pour parler chez cash
avec ses puces et pour se marrer il ya
plein d'autres si on parle vraiment un
échec échec ou quand on joue
ou n'est title tuesday où ces choses là
on parle quand même plus d'échecs là
c'est plus un moment détente
ouais ce petit moment fraîcheur quoi
donc là ce délai les liens d'un master
class tout ça va regarder c est chaud ou
pas et puis du coup bah moi je suis allé
à cannes est donc bon on verra c'est
déjà demain on fait un truc sinon il y
aura toute façon chaque jour on voit des
choses en main et demain à tonton voilà
aller